il y a un peu plus d'un an Florent Pagny
était contraint d’interrompre sa tournée
et de faire cette annonce bouleversante
à ses fans sur les réseaux sociaux on
vient de me diagnostiquer une tumeur au
poumon et tandis qu'il avait livré des
nouvelles plutôt rassurantes il y a
quelques mois lors d'une émission de
télévision
mieux c'est que les programmes marchent
de mieux en mieux le chanteur c'est
cette fois dévoiler face aux caméras de
TF1 des caméras qui l'ont suivi à Paris
à New York mais aussi en Patagonie
résultat une interview de près de 30
minutes qui a été diffusée hier dans 7 à
8 qui a ému les téléspectateurs je ne
pensais pas être aussi touché par le
témoignage de Florent Pagny guerrier
alors comment se porte le chanteur
aujourd'hui Florent Pagny sort du
silence sur son combat contre le cancer
tout savoir ce soir dans TPMP
merci Michael Dorian merci Mickaël
d'être là vous êtes journaliste et
spécialiste de la chanson française
merci merci de m'accueillir j'adore la
chanson française moi donc on peut que
bien s'entendre et Roger Rua qui est
bienvenue nous voir on rappelle un flash
les médecins généralistes toujours sympa
Roger toujours merci d'être là
Roger de quoi souffre Florent Pagny
alors il souffre d'un cancer du poumon
c'est
une affection malheureusement
assez fréquente chez les fumeurs et il
sait qu'il a fumé donc il est au courant
et s'il avait su il a subi un traitement
classique jusqu'à présent et devait
subir une immunothérapie qui est la
fonction actuellement de thérapeutique
la plus la plus évoluée qui donne
d'excellents résultats et puis bon pour
des raisons XYZ il a un petit peu décalé
et se trouve que là il a découvert
l'apparition
d'un petit d'un ganglion on va dire ça
comme ça qui pour l'instant ne peut pas
être qualifié de métastases parce qu'on
que je connais pas son dossier
évidemment puisque il y a le secret
médical mais bon qui pourrait
éventuellement être une métastase de son
premier concert alors que le premier
cancer était à peu près résolu c'est ça
semble-t-il alors justement il a dit
j'en ai j'en ai j'ai passé un examen il
y a très peu de temps parce que je me
suis retrouvé avec une énorme teinte de
tout où là ça m'a rappelé mes débuts de
cette histoire j'ai quand même été vite
faire un aller-retour à Buenos Aires
pour faire des images
et visiblement comme dit le résultat de
ces examens n'était pas bon les images
elles ne sont pas terribles dans trois
jours je rentre à Paris pour aller voir
ce qui se passe il y a un ganglion qui a
fixé ce qui fait qu'il y a des risques
de métastases est-ce que vous nous
expliquez il y a un instant
Michael il est où actuellement Florent
Pagny alors pour le moment on le sait
pas moi j'étais personnellement assez
gêné en fait par le reportage d'hier
parce que il faut quand même prendre un
peu de recul nous à ce reportage a fait
paniquer beaucoup beaucoup de gens bien
sûr à la radio le matin moi on a reçu
énormément de messages de fans qui se
sont inquiétés pour pour Florent Pagny
il faut prendre aussi du recul je crois
dans le sens où alors prévoit la je suis
pas je suis pas médecin mais ce
reportage a été tourné il y a il y a un
mois et demi deux mois
il parle de d'examen qui doit passer à
Paris donc on peut effectivement
imaginer qu'il est à l'heure actuelle
à Paris maintenant
les résultats de ces examens on les
connaît pas
il est très inquiet visiblement dans ce
reportage qu'on voit mais avant de faire
ces examens on peut imaginer que les
choses vont bien aujourd'hui pour lui on
peut en tous les cas garder
de l'espoir il y a une proche de Florent
Pagny qui est ma deux Gonzalez qui est
une productrice de spectacle qui connaît
très bien Florent qui
organise ces tourner et qui organise
notamment les concerts de Florent qui
qui sont prévus cet été puisque Florent
doit remonter sur scène cet été pour une
tournée de 15 dates de de festival elle
a donné de ses nouvelles il l'aurait
appelé après ce reportage pour lui dire
qu'il allait bien et qu'il avait hâte de
retrouver son public donc on peut
imaginer deux mois après ce tournage que
les résultats il les connaît et que si
les résultats étaient si mauvais que ça
il aurait annulé ces dates de concert
déjà donc moi c'est la première chose
qui qui l'a passé six mois en Patagonie
il suivait le traitement là-bas
absolument il suivait plus du tout
maintenant il avait arrêté son
traitement puisque effectivement le
traitement qu'il n'a pas voulu suivre
comme vient de le dire le docteur c'est
à cette immunothérapie qui ne l'a pas
voulu suivre à Paris pour retourner en
Patagonie à la fin de sa chimiothérapie
et c'est un traitement qui visiblement
en Argentine est un peu compliqué à
suivre alors dans l'interview on le sent
la tête tout ça puisqu'on le rappelle
c'est plus d'un an qu'il est suivi
Florent Pagny il y a toujours quelque
chose qui finit par réapparaître l'autre
fois c'était les tâches blanches
maintenant c'est un ganglion qui marque
j'ai pas fait le traitement
d'immunothérapie alors il faut que je
retourne vite le faire
il dit voilà comme il avait décidé de
repartir en Patagonie un contre l'avis
des médecins qui souhaitaient contrôler
et le faire suivre des traitements après
sa rémission
une réaction voilà qui l'assume
totalement j'ai trop profité de tout ça
la Patagonie peut-être que si j'avais
été en France tu aurais peut-être pas
second million qui apparaît comme ça et
si j'avais suivi le programme prévu
peut-être c'est peut-être un peu de ma
faute
en même temps on ne va pas non plus
avoir peur et on va pas flipper on va
faire ce qu'on a à faire je sens bien
que je ne suis toujours pas je me
réveille des fois un peu fatigué donc
j'aurais préféré être là à rigoler à
balancer des vannes à dire tout va bien
c'est nickel il n'y a rien qui est
revenu ce n'est pas le cas
donc
aujourd'hui donc il va il va reprendre
les concerts il va pouvoir rechanter il
va il va venir sur scène alors rechanter
il y a franchement rien qui pourrait
l'empêcher de chanter il il a même
tendance à chimiothérapie il a continué
de chanter il a même enregistré un duo
avec Kenji sur le dernier album de
kendji il l'a enregistré pendant sa
chimiothérapie donc
les capacités de champ de Florent Pagny
là on en doute pas remonter sur scène il
va le faire il y a 15 dates qui sont qui
sont prévues sur une tournée de festival
alors après on peut effectivement se
poser des questions sur son sur sa
capacité physique sur son état aussi de
fatigue c'est pour ça qu'il a pas repris
la tournée qu'il avait interrompu
l'année dernière évidemment vous savez
que sur des festivals la cette liste est
beaucoup plus réduite que sur une une
tournée donc on peut imaginer que pour
le moment il a envie de de d'y aller en
douceur voilà après moi ce qui ce qui
m'étonne en fait c'est que Florent ne se
soit pas encore prononcé publiquement
suite à la diffusion du reportage d'hier
voilà il laisse en suspens et encore une
fois c'est inquiète c'est fans je vous
dis à la radio on a reçu énormément de
messages et et c'est vrai qu'il n'a pas
il ne sait pas exprimé alors que depuis
le début de sa maladie il communiquait
énormément si notamment sur Instagram
donc on aurait pu attendre qu'après ce
reportage qui est encore une fois été
tourné il y a près de deux mois il
s'exprime pour dire bah voilà les
examens dont on les a fait et voilà ce
qu'il en est il a pas fait pour le
moment peut-être cette semaine au
lendemain
quand il dit j'ai profité de tout ça
peut-être si j'avais été en France
j'aurais peut-être pas ce ganglions qui
apparaît comme ça si j'avais suivi le
programme prévu peut-être il dit c'est
un peu de sa faute parce que ce serait
pu être évité ou pas du tout non faut
pas qui se responsabilise sur sa propre
faute il a fait ce qu'il a cru de voir
faire il l'a bien fait il y a certains
malades chez qui ça aurait pu marcher et
rien ne serait rien n'est apparu non là
c'est malheureusement le fait du cancer
qui peut toujours se casser
donc il a pas autorité voilà d'avoir
profité en plus en patagon
en plus pour le reportage et moi je l'ai
vu hier
il y a le décalage entre le mais c'est
ça le temps bien sûr comme on le voyait
hier il avait pas l'air malade du tout
enfin je veux dire il va aller en plein
de santé donc on peut pas imaginer que
il est une situation qui se soit
dégradée très rapidement donc
souvenez-vous pour l'instant on a vu
Florent Pagny dans un état bien moins
voilà notamment dans The Voice l'année
dernière où il avait les traits tirés ou
il était en pleine chimiothérapie voilà
Gilles oui docteur il dit quand même à
plusieurs reprises qu'il est fatigué il
se sent fatigué est-ce que vous pouvez
avec un protocole de soins
potentiellement efficace imaginez qu'il
ressent dès cet été alors le signe
positif de tout le reportage c'est que
ça voit et à un moment il finit par
chanter mais pas du tout altéré par la
maladie alors sa voix probablement pas
parce que ça concerne ces cordes vocales
mais par contre le le souffle la
capacité la santé la force physique pour
le faire c'est autre chose heureusement
sa voix ne sera ne sera pas affectée par
cette maladie là en particulier parce
que c'est pulmonaire et donc c'est juste
le soufflet qui vous a manqué et non pas
les cordes vocales qui donnent son
timbre et ça son talent en fait bien sûr
oui Jean-Marie oui ben le c'est
l'immunothérapie qui va si se déclencher
c'est quand même un remède très efficace
pour en tout cas prolonger les personnes
qui ont un cancer du poumon donc il fait
bien de rentrer en France et il fait
bien et on espère que va avoir des
résultats très positifs avec
l'immunothérapie alors vous avez parlé
de Stéphane c'est vrai que c'est fan
était tous 5 hier on est aussi et quand
on a vu le documentaire de de TF1
aujourd'hui comme quand ils ont réagi
est-ce qu'ils ont plus d'infos que nous
parce que souvent que les fans vont les
fans ils ont plus d'infos que les
encore une fois les messages qu'on a
reçu étaient des messages inquiets donc
effectivement il n'avait pas plus
d'infos que que nous ils sont tous ils
ont vu comme nous le reportage hier de
TF1
beaucoup ne n'avaient pas forcément
compris aussi que le reportage avait été
tourné il y a deux mois donc certains se
disent voilà mais
moins bien maintenant ou est-ce qu'il va
mieux c'est ça l'histoire c'est c'est le
c'est le truc en fait on se dit comme
c'était il y a deux mois est-ce que là
il est il a traitement c'est toujours
lui qui choisit sa communication c'est
lui qui a toujours décidé qui a toujours
pris la main qui a décidé quand il
parlait quand il se faisait il maîtrise
tout donc là on peut supposer aussi que
si il a pas envie de parler c'est qu'il
a pas envie de parler point
d'interrogation
peut-être la semaine peut-être qu'il va
il va parler en fin de semaine on
comprend aussi que il est pas envie de
parler tout de suite tout de suite et ça
productrice enfin la productrice qui
s'occupe des spectacles de cet été en
tous les cas affirmé qu'elle avait eu au
téléphone ce matin et qu'il y avait
donné des nouvelles positives donc
docteur il est il était il était guéri
de
son concert est-ce qu'on peut guérir
d'un cancer oui oui il faut que les
téléspectateurs sachent qu'on peut
guérir un cancer aujourd'hui on guérit
un certain nombre de cancer avec des
proportions qui sont très importantes
jusqu'à 90% de guérison pour le cancer
du colon quand même
quand on parle de guérison c'est plus de
5 ans sans aucune apparition d'autres
signes et donc c'est quelque chose que
tout le monde doit savoir on peut guérir
il y a des traitements qui sont parfois
dur à supporter qui sont difficiles moi
je retiens sa phrase il dit il y a
toujours un truc après qui qui apparaît
les tâches blanches ou bien des
ganglions et c'est vrai que c'est pas
obligatoire c'est souvent on peut guérir
les femmes qui ont viré de leur cancer
du sein il y a plus de 25 ans
aujourd'hui qui n'ont strictement plus
rien et donc là sous concert des poumons
pour lui c'était derrière lui donc là
c'est toujours compliqué mais dans la
même moralement de se dire je vais
devoir repartir peut-être sur un
traitement c'est des traitements très
lourd forcément
éliminothérapie c'est ça dans un cas
comme celui d'en face de ce qu'il semble
dire ça ça c'est quoi ça ça suffirait
comme traitement c'est le traitement
actuel le plus performant que que l'on
est contre ce type de cancer oui ça doit
pouvoir suffire et il pourrait à nouveau
avoir une guérison qui puisse durer
encore quelques années d'accord donc
c'est c'est pas trop inquiet enfin les
fans n'ont pas de grandes raisons de
s'inquiéter outre mesure pour l'instant
les fans sont toujours inquiets
mais non non il faut et il a
manifestement une volonté il gère
effectivement sa communication mais il a
une volonté personnelle qui est assez
forte moi je l'avais vu une fois quand
j'étais président de syndicat dans une
autre vie et pour une manifestation nous
avait aimablement donné les droits de sa
chanson
pour la liberté la liberté de penser la
lumière peut-être penser voilà vous avez
donné aux élections gratuites de
l'utiliser pendant la manifestation
quelqu'un très sympathique et encore une
fois souvenez-vous il y a un an
lorsqu'il annonce sa maladie la première
chose qui fait c'est annuler c'est
interrompre sa tournée donc le fait que
ces concerts soient maintenus depuis
décembre depuis novembre sont maintenus
pour pour cet été peut quand même
laisser entrevoir un espoir concernant
les résultats des examens qui ont été
faits par Florent Pagny